[Musik]
hier lieben heute gibt es endlich die
giotto torte die ich euch versprochen
habe weil so so so viele von euch gesagt
haben kiki macht doch mal richtig
leckere torte vor allem eine die nicht
so schwer im magen liegt und jetzt habe
ich für euch das perfekte rezept
entwickelt und ich habe ich hier schon
die zutaten für die leckere haselnuss
creme
dafür benötigen wir schlagsahne bitte
ganz kalt aus dem kühlschrank helle
haselnuss creme außerdem etwas vanille
extrakt die sahne fest dann habe ich
hier noch mascarpone und natürlich
leckere giotto kirche und was wir auch
noch benötigen ist einmal ein
schokoladen bis geboten
den habe ich hier das ist auch noch mal
ein kleiner tipp für euch den habe ich
hier unter einem feuchten sauberen
geschirrtuch damit ja auch nicht
austrocknet schon durch geschnitten so
dass wir drei dünne böden haben und dem
boden trinke ich gleich noch mit etwas
kaffee und den rest den genieße ich dann
einfach während des backens selbst
starten mit der creme und die geht auch
echt weh denn ich mag das ja immer ganz
gerne die creme der küchenmaschine
aufzuschlagen in dem ich alles rein gebe
wichtig jetzt halt nur die reihenfolge
ich gebe als erstes mascarpone rein dann
seine damit eben nicht so auf plumpe und
nicht die ganze küche eingebaut ist das
ist einfache grund dafür
dann gebe ich die haselnuss creme dazu
daniela extrakt und dann wird es erst
mal geschlagen erst niedrig dann immer
ein bisschen höher und nach einer minute
kommt es seine fest dazu
[Musik]
nach insgesamt dreieinhalb minuten ist
unsere creme auch schon fertig und gebe
hier jetzt ungefähr ein fünftel an die
seite das brauchen wir gleich noch zum
bestreichen der äußeren torte und für
die schönen lupfer die warum drauf geben
könnte auch so lange gerne im
kühlschrank stellen und zu rechtlichen
themen gebe ich jetzt klein gehackte
oder kleine vierte giottos rein und ihr
habt vielleicht schon gemerkt ich habe
hier eigentlich kein süßungsmittel drin
also hier die giottos die sind ja auch
schon süß die harte nuss krimis und mehr
braucht ihr auch gar nicht
und ihr kennt schon vor mir wein
konstrukt ich habe ja immer wenn nicht
orten gefühle oder generell will ich
dort mache immer ein ganz bestimmtes
konstrukt habe ganz unten eine drehbare
tortenplatte die hilft euch enormes geht
an alle super easy von der hand darüber
die tortenplatte die ihr am liebsten
mögen für die torte meisten sollte das
dann auch farblich passt nicht zum
beispiel rot und danach brauchen wir
einen tortenring ich gehe jetzt
zuallererst den ersten boden ganz unten
rein drängte den mit kaffee ihr könnt
auch wenn er zum beispiel kinder mit
essen oder er hat mir einfach keinen
kaffee mögt dann könntet ihr auch kakao
nehmen oder was auch lecker ist er milch
mit haselnuss druck stechen auch celica
vor
und dann gehen wir auch schon die hälfte
der creme dazu
[Musik]
so die torte isst geschichtet und jetzt
gebe ich hier einfach einen jackpot
obendrauf damit eben nicht austrocknet
ihr könnt ihr auch gerne ein tuch nehmen
wenn ihr mögt und dann muss die ganze
torte jetzt noch mal für zwei stunden
gekühlt werden dann wird die creme auch
richtig schön fest könnte den tortenring
entfernt und danach zeige ich euch die
deko bis gleich so die wartezeit ist rum
und jetzt können wir die torte
dekorieren das tolle ist wir haben jetzt
hier noch die creme von eben also wir
müssen uns keine neue creme aufschlagen
jetzt werde ich erstmal die torte
rundherum ganz dünn damit einstreichen
wenn wir nicht mehr mandl krokant für
die seiten und natürlich ein paar
giottos für obendrauf
[Musik]
ich persönlich liebe mandl krokant
deswegen habe ich heute den genommen ihr
könnt jetzt aber auch zum beispiel
haselnuss krokant nehmen oder sogar
gehackte und geröstete haselnüsse für
den rand der torte geben und dann habe
ich immer heute mal meine blumen hülle
genommen und mal so ein ganz anderes
fans sie muster gemacht auf die torte
also nicht dieses klassische diese
klassischen tupfer die man so kennt zwar
jetzt gerade so ein fall
also macht es gerne genauso nach denn
ich finde sie total beeindruckend aus
und im anschluss seht ihr natürlich auch
noch den anschnitt und dann lassen wir
uns die schmecken nachher kommen noch
meinen eltern also passt das eigentlich
wunderbar dass wir die leckere torte
heute gemacht haben euch jetzt ganz viel
freude beim nachbacken schreibt mir
unbedingt in die kommentare welches
rezept ihr als nächstes sehen möchte hat
eine besondere süßigkeit die ihr immer
essen könnt und soll ich daraus eine
torte zaubern dann schreibt man auf
jeden fall hier rein
ansonsten findet ihr die genauen
mengenangaben in der video beschreibung
und natürlich dürft ihr das abo nicht
vergessen denn dann bekommt ihr auch mit
witz wieder so leckere torten auf einem
kanal gibt hast du auch noch was zu
sagen ich bin okay ich habe daraufhin zu
reden euch noch einen wunderschönen tag
und bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis
kitchen tschüss
[Musik]